ja herzlich willkommen das basler
kunstmuseum von das jo baier zeigt
derzeit werke des malers baltus das ist
mutig denn einige seiner bilder sind
mehr als umstritten
die raver 80 jahre nach seinem entstehen
sorgte das gemälde erst kürzlich wieder
für einen skandal
es hing in new york 12.000 menschen
forderte mit der online petition dass es
abgehängt werde
das mädchen werde sexualisiert
dargestellt eine us debatte um
pädophilie im zeichen von meet u nun
hängt das bild in der fundación para la
rue ist an nie zur debatte das bild
wegen dieser kontroverse nicht zu zeigen
im gegenteil gerade wenn ein werk so
umstritten ist soll man es zeigen damit
sich jeder seine eigene meinung bilden
kann
ja darf man solche bilder heute noch
zeigen und was sagt die tatsache dass
wir so hitzig darüber debattieren über
unsere zeit darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit dem kunstkritiker hannover hat der
berg herzlich willkommen ja vielen dank
für die einladung
ja dieses bild hier ist das gute kunst
ist das böse kunst oder beides na ja die
frage nach der moral eines solchen
bildes die liegt eigentlich nicht im
werk selber begründet sondern wir als
betrachter müsst ihr immer entscheiden
was wir dort sehen und ob es uns
anstößig vorkommt unsittlich vorkommt
oder ob wir finden dass das im rahmen
der freien kunst auch möglich sein
sollte mich jedenfalls hat die debatte
im letzten jahr die von amerika aus ging
sehr überrascht bin ja schon so ein paar
jährchen im kunstkritiker geschäft also
glauben sogar 20 jahre mittlerweile eine
solche aufflammende empörung habe ich
bislang noch nicht erlebt und das hat
sicherlich auch was mit diesen neuen
medialen möglichkeiten zu tun eben mit
der petition die man im internet starten
kann und plötzlich sind 10.000 12.000
leute hellauf empört ja ich glaube
vorher gab es auch immer schon wieder
menschen dieses aufgeregt haben über
diese bilder aber es wurde nicht so
öffentlich wirksamer verstehen dass sie
das überhaupt nicht wenn sie dieses bild
anschauen dass leute
wie sagen das ist doch pädophil hier
wird dann 13 mehr jähriges mädchen
künstler in so eine pose gezwungen da
wird er zeichnet und jetzt gezeigt leute
die sowas erlebt haben vielleicht um der
jugend führen sie sich doch verletzt
naja wenn sie sich angucken wie oft über
pädophilie gestritten wird wie oft es
auch in populären formaten wie krimis
und so weiter zum thema wird
kindesmissbrauch oder denken sie an die
diskussion jetzt rund um die katholische
kirche wo priester sich an kindern
vergangen haben
ja aber das ist nicht alles dinge die
hinein spielen dann in die rezeption
eines solches solchen bild ist das
meinte ich vorhin also man kann solche
bilder nie losgelöst betrachten
losgelöst von der zeit in der wir leben
und ganz klar stand diese protest im
letzten jahr auch im zeichen der mito
debatte ja aber hier wird diese
vorpubertäre erotik ja sozusagen
ästhetisiert dargestellt oder ist das
schon wieder eine interpretation frage
na ja das ist ja immer das interessante
an solchen bildern bei dem wir das
gefühl haben sie gehen über die üblichen
charme grenzen hinweg dass wir mal nicht
genau wissen ist das bild jetzt
möglicherweise selber kinder per
pornografische oder bilden für uns das
nur ein dass solche dinge dort in diesem
bild drin sind und von baltus selber ist
glaube ich nicht überliefert dass er
tatsächlich kinder missbraucht hätte
dass sie sich mit kindern in keiner
weise erregend umgeben hätte er hat
immer wieder kinder gemalt ganz klar es
ist ein fantasieprodukt das ist ja erst
ist ein fantasieprodukt ganz richtig
aber ist es dann schon missbraucht wenn
man ein kind in einer solchen pose in
szene setzt
bin ich mir nicht sicher ich glaube dass
kunst sowie es dort in new york
gefordert wurde nicht weggesperrt werden
sollte schon deshalb auch solche
fragwürdigen möglicherweise fragwürdigen
bilder nicht weggesperrt werden sollten
denn erst in der diskussion darüber
wurde in unsere schamgrenzen verlaufen
wo denn eigentlich für uns schluss ist
mit der freiheit der kunst um es mal
zugespitzt zu formulieren es in solchen
diskussionen merkten wir ja wo diese
grenzen sich befinden wenn das bild weg
wäre dann müssten wir gar nicht genau wo
unser
womöglich haben soll sitzt oder was für
uns bieten lassen wollen was wir uns
nicht ja ja sie wollen von künstlern
genau so eine diskussion so eine debatte
wurde auch angestoßen in manchester wo
ein anderes bild vorübergehend abgehängt
wurde von john barry waterhouse coopers
um die nymphen bisher dass hier die
kuratorin hat das abgehängten hat
gefordert man sollte kommentare dahin
schreiben oder das bild eingenommen hat
um zu diskutieren darüber wie man heute
mit solchen bildern umgeht die
klassischerweise diese rollenklischees
fixieren und diesen männlichen immer
wieder perpetuieren willen zeigen ja ich
finde das wurde auch mit großer hysterie
aufgenommen wurde sofort darüber geklagt
jetzt heißt wirklich aus mit der
freiheit der kunst wenn jetzt solche
bilder schon ins depot verbannt würden
mir kam das übertrieben vor vor allem
deshalb weil es sich um eine
künstlerische intervention gehandelt hat
und künstler haben ja immer wieder den
status des museums befragt haben immer
wieder gefragt ist das was im museum zu
sehen ist eigentlich wirklich die ganze
kunst oder müssen wir den kanon
erweitern müssen wir andere bilder
das heißt von frauen seines bilder von
männern auch in diesen kanon aufnehmen
und tatsächlich wenn man sich die museen
anguckt europäische museen anguckt dann
fällt schon auf dass sehr wenige
künstlerinnen dort zu sehen sind dafür
aber sehr viele nackte frauen auf den
bildern der männer und entsprechend gibt
es immer wieder proteste seit
jahrzehnten schon proteste von frauen
die sagen mensch wir wollen auch mal ins
museum kommen ohne uns auszuziehen
vor allem mahler der uns dann malt wir
wollen auch als künstlerin ernst
genommen werden und dort vertreten sein
das heißt sie finden diese debatte
wichtig diese kuratoren angesprochen die
frage nach dem kanon ist zentral
ich würde nur immer versuchen sie etwas
anders zu wenden diese diskussion
darüber
insofern als es immer darum gehen sollte
meiner meinung nach der runde kann und
zu erweitern und das war auch lange der
impetus viele feministisch eingestellter
künstlerin gesagt haben okay ihr zeigt
sehr viele nackte frauen im museum jetzt
wollen wir mal sehen wo das sind die
nackten männer und zeigt doch bitte mehr
auch darf und oder auch nackte kinder
egal also dieses dieser diese bewegung
zu sagen wir wollen das bestehende
sprenge wollen konventionen aushebeln
das war immer der impetus der moderne
und entsprechend ging es daneben auch
darum emanzipation als erweiterung zu
denken was wir heute erleben dass er
eine einengung eine einhegung
eingrenzung bilder sollen abgehängt
werden nicht nur innerhalb einer
künstlerischen performance sondern
dauerhaft nach möglichkeit viele
menschen ins museum gehen haben ungute
gefühle wie sie sagen und sie wollen
sich aber noch möglichkeit wohlfühlen im
museum sie wollen sich bestätigt fühlen
und das hat mit der klassischen moderne
wurde künstler hemer auch der
provokateur war nur noch relativ wenig
zu tun
also es wird ja auch in diesem
zusammenhang gefordert dass man die
bilder kommentiert oder warnschilder
aufhängt und so weiter dass solche
gefühle nicht nicht wieder hoch kommen
solche termathe vielleicht bestimmte
leute erlebt haben mit sexueller
belästigung was halten sie denn von
diesen vorschlägen dass man einfach die
werke besser nochmal kontextualisiert
oder frauchen unguten gefühlen die
betrachterinnen schützt ja ja das ist
immer schwerer so ganz global zu
beantworten es gibt ja auch in deutschen
museen oder auch in schweizer museen
immer wieder so hinweise wo es heißt
mensch hier könnte es um gewalt gehen
hier könnte es um sexuelle gewalt gehen
in dieser videoarbeit beispielsweise
wenn sie mit kindern im museum sind
seien sie gewarnt
aber am ende kann es ja jeder für sich
selbst entscheiden ob er ein bestimmtes
bild anschauen will ob er eine sich
einer künstlerischen erfahrung aussetzen
möchte deswegen bin ich mir nicht ganz
sicher ob es so viel bringt jetzt neben
den bildern immer so längliche
warnschilder aufzubauen und so eine art
betreutes sehen anzuleiten ich habe gar
nichts dagegen dass man historischen
hintergrund auch mit hinein in die
rezeption im gegenteil das ist
wichtig zu verstehen aus welchem recht
zusammenhängen ein werk heraus
entstanden ist um es auch besser zu
begreifen
trotzdem bin ich auch ein freund der
vorstellung dass die unmittelbare
begegnung mit der kunst auch eine
wertvolle erfahrung ist eine ästhetische
erfahrung in der ich erst mal nicht
alles was ich immer schon weiß mitnehmen
sondern mich erstmal berühren lassen von
der kunst und dann in einem zweiten
schritt für schritt anfange zu
reflektieren wo es ist eigentlich
entstanden wer hat es gemalt was waren
die intention dabei also so eine arglose
ein vielleicht auch sogar naiver zugang
zur kunst kommt mir wichtig vor wenn wir
uns denn in der kunst auch ein wenig
verlieren wollen wenn wir uns im
angesicht der kunst ort befremden lassen
wollen und sie sagen dieses befremden
lassen das kommt heute immer weniger vor
sie haben einen essay geschrieben mit
dem titel wie frei ist die kunst und die
hauptthese ist wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe dass wir derzeit eine krise der
freiheit insgesamt erleben nicht nur der
kunstfreiheit woran zeigt sich das denn
naja wir merken einerseits und wenn ich
hier sage dann sage ich vor allem wir
westeuropäer oder wir menschen des
nordens wir privilegierten wir in einer
zeit in der wir glaube ich mehr
freiheiten haben denn je und ein medium
dieser freiheit ist ganz bestimmt das
internet wo plötzlich eine historisch
einmalige situation jeder zum autor
werden kann
es braucht gar nicht mehr die
vermittelnden organe es brauchte ich mir
dass fans fehlt die zeitung oder andere
medien sondern jeder kann unmittelbar zu
aller welt sprechen und kann auf alle
welt empfangen und diese autoren status
ist natürlich einerseits toll
andererseits hören auch viele menschen
wie gefährden das ist viele menschen das
gefühl sie verlieren die kontrolle über
ihre eigenen bilder zum beispiel und
nochmal auf die kunst zurückzukommen
wir sind ja heute alle oder zumindest
die generation der 20 30 jährigen sind
fast schon verpflichtend in irgend einem
sozialen netzwerk und
wegs um zu existieren könnte man sagen
braucht man eine mediale repräsentation
seiner selbst bei facebook twitter oder
wie auch immer wir können natürlich auch
sagen ich halte mich da raus sehen sie
darin ich bin nicht drin aber ich bin
natürlich in einer zeit hoch
also ich bin auf andere weise medial
präsent sie sind bestellt beispielen und
erfreuten chef der wochenzeitung die
zeit wieder leicht noch sagen auch schon
50 oder 51 sogar ich sehe es bei den
jüngeren verstärkt dass wir das gefühl
haben sie müssen im netz auch präsent
sein und das heißt sie müssen auch sich
in gewisser weise schutzlos machen denn
sie können ihre eigenen bilder die dort
kursieren nur bis zu einem bestimmten
gerade überhaupt kontrollieren
also das ist eine freiheit und
gleichzeitig eine erfahrung der
unfreiheit weil ich weiß ja auch nicht
genau was ich im netz eigentlich was ich
mit meinem netz im was ich im netz mit
meinen daten alles so was da passiert
gewiss ja die nsa hört alles abspeichert
alles sogar das kanzlerin das handy der
deutschen kanzlerin wird abgehört zu
hieß es ja mal ich bin sozusagen
gezwungen eine bestimmte form von
öffentlichkeit zu suchen ohne dass ich
wüsste was in dieser öffentlichkeit mit
mir geschieht mit meiner medialen
repräsentation geschieht das ist nur so
ein beispiel also dass ich auf der einen
seite die möglichkeiten habe unglaublich
viele freiheiten zu genießen und auf der
anderen seite ich immer mehr leute
beobachtet die das gefühl haben wird die
freiheit zu viel wir erleben dass auch
auf politischer ebene also der praxis
beispielsweise oder was in ungarn
passiert oder in polen passiert das sind
alles bewegung wo leute sagen ich will
lieber wieder klare autoritäten klare
strukturen überschaubare pole zwischen
gut und böse
ich will diese ganze multifunktionalität
des netzes nicht und deshalb einfache
lösung haben wollen und gerade die kunst
ist ja etwas wenn wir uns der kunst
hingehen wo wir merken einfache lösungen
gibt es nicht die kunst ist ja
eigentlich ein medium in dem vieles in
zweifel gezogen wird
und deswegen wird jetzt plötzlich die
kunst auch in zweifel gezogen so könnten
die kunst stand halt jahrhunderte laufe
diese öffnung für diese provokation
entgrenzung entdeckten und heute werden
grenzen immer wieder wichtiger und diese
schließung die sie angesprochen haben
diese bestätigung wir könnten später
nochmal darüber genau diskutieren diese
gesellschaftlichen fragen ich würde
jetzt noch mal interessierten bei der
kunst finden sie denn es sollte gar
keine grenzen geben der kunstfreiheit
darf kunst alles nein das ist ja schon
juristisch geregelt dass sie nicht alles
darf es gibt zum beispiel die grenze des
persönlichkeitsschutzes also ein
künstler dürfte mich jetzt einfach ihr
leben nehmen oder ihr bildnis nehmen und
dieses bild dann einfach in seine kunst
hinein verwursten dann könnten sie
dagegen klagen und bei öffentlichen
personen oder personen des öffentlichen
lebens ist es so dass die sich dann sehr
viel gefallen lassen müssen aber bei
privatpersonen beispielsweise nicht oder
auch gewaltverherrlichung ist etwas wo
die gesetzgeber auch grenzen gezogen
haben und wenn sie mich jetzt fragen wo
für mich selber grenzen verlaufen würde
ich immer sage es ist schwierig man
musste sich das genau angucken die
einzelfälle aber so ein fall wie zum
beispiel die arbeit von santiago sierra
der immer wieder menschen die sehr wenig
verdienen die unterprivilegiert sind für
seine performance ins einsetzt und dann
müssen diese armen teufel um es mal so
zu sagen
einen ganzen tag lang unter pappkartons
sitzen oder müssen sich eine linie auf
den rücken tätowieren lassen die machen
das freiwillig an in anführungszeichen
weil sie dafür bezahlt werden
und dann heißt es aus dem publikum
natürlich immer wie kann man das machen
das ist doch unmöglich das ist doch eine
mission
das ist doch menschenschinderei und dann
sagt santiago sierra immer in der nähe
das ist doch die wirklichkeit in
wahrheit passiert es doch überall auf
der welt dass sich leute für sehr wenig
geld prostituieren
ob das jetzt wahr prostitution ist oder
nur im übertragenen sinn hat es sich
ausbeuten lassen
also wenn ihr euch über meine kunst
aufgeregt wenn es das prägt euch darüber
über die wahren verhältnisse dort
draußen in der welt auf so weit okay
das problem wird wenn das beim so ein
problem wird es dann wenn santiago
sierra dieser art von performance in
ähnlicher weise immer wieder variiert
und immer aufs neue auf man hat es dann
verstanden und er macht aber immer
weiter macht immer weiter diese menschen
zu objekten seiner kunst und da habe ich
das gefühl da beginnt ist für mich
zweifelhaft zu werden obwohl man sagen
könnte das system läuft ja auch immer
weiter und diese unterdrückung da ist
vielleicht wähler dass damit sie
eigentlich keine ja aber als betrachter
hat man sich ja dann auch irgendwann mal
verstanden er das ist problematisch ist
jetzt sagen sie ja die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen die gibt es aber
derzeit werden die noch engel gemacht
nämlich durch die moral
ja also wir haben ja in der
kunstgeschichte immer wieder fälle
erlebt in denen es zensur bestrebungen
gab und es war eigentlich immer der
staat es war immer es immer waren es
eigentlich die mächtigen die auf die
künstler herr abgeschaut haben gesagt
das lasse ich mir jetzt nicht bieten
auch noch in den 90er jahren in diesem
berühmten kultur kämpfen in den
vereinigten staaten sind entweder
klerikale kreise sagt hat es doch
blasphemisch geht nicht und ein
marienbild aus elefanten dunk furchtbar
muss weg oder das museum dass solche
sachen zeigt darf nicht länger gefördert
werden solche forderungen gab es damals
oder das war halt der staat er gesagt
hat das lassen wir uns nicht bieten das
ist unsittlich und die bevölkerung hat
das nicht darf somit solchen kunstwerk
nicht konfrontiert werden und was für zu
erleben sind eher protestbewegung von
unten so wie wir es bei baltus erlebt
haben leute die sich zusammenschließen
dieser begriff des klickt iwis muss ist
ja gerade sehr populäre menschen
erwiesen jahr clickjacking also die
brauchen eigentlich nur kurze petition
aufsetzen
zack gibt es einen großen großen
shitstorm wie das dann heißt und
künstler aber auch museums menschen mit
denen ich spreche die fürchten sich vor
dieser art des digitalen mops
das ist auch so ein begriff der immer
wieder fällt dafür ja das gefühl in
streit da da gibt es so oder so gibt
solche mächte die lassen sich gar nicht
mehr kontrollieren im museum kann ich
vieles erklären wenn die leute zu mir
kommen und vor dem einzelnen kunstwerk
diskutieren dann kann ich dagegen halten
aber dieser anonym welten des internets
wo sich eben dieser diese wut dann
plötzlich so entgeht was soll ich da
machen kann ich gar nichts kann ich gar
nicht mehr dagegenhalten aber das kann
er sein dass diese wut leberecht ist
also wenn es minderheiten sind die
diskriminiert werden und das in der
kunst sogar noch gezeigt wird oder der
ganze prozess also werden dann später
auch ihre künstler sprechen die vorwürfe
sexueller belästigung haben und so
weiter dann ist eine systemfrage über
minderheiten oder bestimmte
marginalisierte gruppen darunter leiden
und dann ist das doch sehr berechtigt
diese wut ja also es kommt dann auch
büromaterial an
wir hatten in den letzten im letzten
jahr auch eine diskussion über das bild
einer weißen künstlerinnen trainer
schadt die einen schwarzen jungen gemalt
hat ein junger mit till der in den 50er
jahren aufs übelste
gelöscht wurde von zwei weißen männern
weil er angeblich einer weißen frau
hinterher gepfiffen haben sollte
entpuppte sich später als lüge und das
bildnis dieses zugerichteten jungen
wurde damals fotografiert und wurde für
die schwarze bürgerrechtsbewegung ganz
wichtig und ein bezugspunkt und jetzt
hat diese weiße künstler in dieses foto
genommen und daraus ein gemälde wie
haben es janke das wurde dich irgendwo
gezeigt sondern auf der whitney biennale
in new york einer der wichtigsten
ausstellung für gegenwartskunst in
amerika und es gab ihm heftige proteste
es fing damit an dass sich künstler
davor aufgebaut haben vor dem bild um es
zu verdecken
es gab dann aber eben auch eine
forderung die forderung einer künstlerin
hannah black die gesagt hat ich als
schwarze wehre mich gegen dieses bild
ich finde eine weiße künstlerin hat kein
recht auf dieses motiv dieses schwarze
motiv wenn man das so nennen will
zuzugreifen und hat überhaupt kein recht
sich mit der schwarz leidensgeschichte
überhaupt zu befassen weil sie als weiße
versteht gar nicht wovon wir als
schwarze community sprechen und das war
schon ein harter eingriff noch härter
dadurch dass sie eigentlich implizit
gefordert hat das bild zu vernichten
hatte auch für die künstlerin den schutz
erhebliche konsequenzen
eine weitere ausstellung die für den
herbst geplant war soll sollte dann bei
kotiert werden wie sollte sich erstmal
öffentlich entschuldigen und künstlern
war auch ganz eingeschüchtert und hat
dann irgendwann gesagt ja es stimmt
vielleicht weiß ich wirklich nicht wie
es den schwarzen er geht vielleicht ist
es wirklich falsch bin ich meine als
weiße künstlerin über so ein schwarzes
thema etwas sagen zu können aber ich als
mutter kann doch immerhin also darf wir
die identitäts frei ich als mutter kann
mich doch einfühlen in das was die
mutter von emmett till mehrmals erhöht
wurde aber natürlich sofort auch
zurückgewiesen weil man sagte eine weiße
mutter kann auch nicht nachempfinden was
eine schwarz mutter empfindet und das
ist deshalb so eine wahnsinnig in meinen
augen wirklich eine harte zäsur weil man
ja immer sagte in der kunst sollte es
denkbar seien
es gehört geradezu zur genuine aufgabe
der kunst sich in dinge hinein zu füllen
die wir selber nicht sind oder die
unsere eigenen erfahrungen übersteigen
und das nicht nur für den künstler
sondern auch für den betrachter darum
geht es ja immer in der kunst dinge zu
entdecken die mir fremd sind die ich so
nicht kannte du hast wie empathie zu
ermöglichen
also wenn ich höre da raus sie halten
eigentlich nicht viel in diesem fall von
dem vorwurf der kulturellen aneignung
und denken das sollte möglich sein dass
eine weiße künstlerin ein bild wie
dieses hier macht und daraus profit oder
sich etabliert und auf die geschichte
der schwarzen der unterdrückung der
schwarzen zurückgreift wer das argument
das von denjenigen verwendet wird die
sich gegen dieses bild aussprachen
ist immer das zu sagen die freiheit der
kunst war immer oder ist auch immer eine
freiheit der privilegierten und das
heißt vor allem eine freiheit der weißen
weiß und wir als schwarzer als
unterdrückte haben über jahrzehnte und
jahrhunderte erleben müssen dass wir
nicht vorkommen und deswegen ist es
jetzt an der zeit dass wir uns wehren
das dach ein gutes argument
ich weiß nicht ob es ein gutes argument
ist im raum des museums im raum der
kunst
ich glaube es ist eine genuin soziale
und eine politische forderung und als
solcher hat diese forderung jede
berechtigung zu sagen wünsche es gab
diese leidensgeschichte es gibt vielen
gesellschaft minderheiten unterdrückt
werden und das muss sich ändern und das
soll sich politisch ändern ich weiß
nicht was damit bezweckt also wenn man
sich künstler wenn man weißen künstlern
verbietet sich in die gedankenwelt
anderer wanderer gruppe anderer gruppen
anderer ethnien hineindenken zu wollen
worin besteht der missbrauch ja aber ich
würde mal sagen es ist doch legitim
insofern aus man sagen könnte dass das
museum oder die kunst soll keine moral
freie zone seien
also warum soll denn das so sein erstens
finde ich also satte wie es gibt zwei
gründe weiß also wie man das bild
kritisieren kann man kann sagen man eine
weise kann das nicht nachvollziehen ich
nicht verstehen oder eben kunstfreiheit
oder redefreiheit war immer die freiheit
der weißen und ich finde an beiden
argumenten es ist wirklich was was dran
und sie müssten wir ja wie noch belegen
warum man jetzt sozusagen den bereich
der kunstmuseums von jeglichen
moralischen überlegungen aber man sollte
also ich würde da gerne deutlich
unterscheiden einmal zwischen einzelnen
kunstwerken auf der einen seite und auf
der anderen seite dem museum als
institution ich glaube das muss ich als
institution ist tatsächlich ein
durchmachte ort wenn man das so nennen
ein ort an dem man sich fragen kann was
passiert dort eigentlich und wer hat
dort das sagen und wer hat das recht
welche bilder zu zeigen welche werke
auszustellen
welche nicht und wir sprachen wir vorhin
schon mal über die geschlechterfrage und
die frage ist es richtig dass so viele
männer in museen präsentiert werden
selbst auch in der gegenwartskunst ist
der männeranteil immer noch
überproportional hoch womit hat das
eigentlich zu tun und dann würde ich
immer fragt nach den strukturen fragen
welche strukturen begünstigen eigentlich
diese art von ungleichheit kann sie wird
wie lässt sich das ändern die lasten
sich mit guten gründen kritisieren wir
diese lassen sich mit guten gründen
kritisieren die frage ist nur inwieweit
greifen diese fragen auch hinein in den
schöpferischen prozess einzelner
künstler soll es tatsächlich sagen wir
jüdischen künstlern untersagt sein sich
in die gedankenwelt palästinensischer
menschen hineinzudenken sich in das
leben palästinensischer menschen
hineinzufühlen oder sagen dann die
palästinensischen menschen also unser
schicksal ist unser schicksal das gehört
alleine uns und allein wir sind
berechtigt aus diesen erfahrungen heraus
auch filme fotos gemälde was auch immer
zu schöpfen
und da würde ich immer sagen nein dass
wir in was für eine ein gecastete
eingegrenzte welt geraten wir denn da
ist geht doch gerade um diese art von
überschreitung darum dass wir in der
kunst uns für einen moment von unseren
klassischen moralvorstellungen
verabschieden man könnte sogar sagen
dass soziale der kunst ist er das
asoziale dass wir uns erlaubt ja frei zu
sein von unseren üblichen
wertvorstellungen und andere werte ins
spiel kommen andere dinge diskutiert
werden können als da draußen außerhalb
erzählkunst was gehen uns werden sonst
reicht mir die kunst ja gar nicht wenn
aber auch nur ein erziehungs raum ist ja
dann brauchen wir nur volkshochschulen
dann brauchen wir keine museen
aber jetzt gibt sozusagen die schwarze
leidensgeschichte und es wird die auch
noch von weißen sozusagen präsentiert
und zu kunst gemacht dann könnte man
doch bitte schön dass den schwarzen
künstlern überlassen könnte man auch
sagen das wetter ja aber diese
geschichte der unterdrückung der
schwarzen oder überhaupt der
unterdrückung von minderheiten ist ja
immer auch eine mindestens 2 teilige
geschichte also es gibt immer die leute
die unterdrückt werden und es gibt auch
die unterdrückt
in dem moment in dem ich sagen nein die
unterdrückten sollen das anrecht haben
das exklusive anrecht haben von ihren
geschichten zu erzählen entlaste ich ja
geradezu die täter und sagen na ja die
opfer werden sich schon selber darum
kümmern die werden ja oft von ihren
geschichten schon erzählen und wenn sie
es nicht tun ist es ja ihr problem nein
es ist doch ein problem das uns alle
betrifft also karl denken sie an an den
holocaust was wäre das für eine seltsame
geschichte bin jetzt den nicht
verfolgten den nicht die hütte menschen
verboten wurde vom holocaust zu sprechen
oder filme zu drehen
mit diesem ganzen thema befassen also
darf finde ich sind wir auf den völlig
falschen spur und eng uns ein aufs
gravierendste 1
[Musik]
ich möchte noch über einen anderen fall
sprechen nämlich das gedicht von eugen
gomringer das in deutschland enorm 4000
medien war in der schweiz sei an einer
hochschule an der alice salomon
hochschule ging das gericht aber nie das
aus dem jahre 1951 und es wurde
gefordert dieses gedicht zu übermalen
was jetzt auch gemacht wird oder schon
gerade in wurden tagen glaub ich will
nur weil dieses gedicht potenziell
sexistisch sei es geht um um straßen und
blumen um frauen und einen bewunderer
der diese frauen und all die anderen
dinge zu objekten macht ihr vorwurf ist
irgendwie sind wir zu empfindlich in der
heutigen zeit
naja ich glaube gar nicht dass ich
sowieso vielen vorwürfen hantiere ich
habe mich sogar ein bisschen darüber
gewundert in meinem buch wundere ich
mich darüber welche heftigen reaktionen
auf dieses vorhaben das gedicht zu
eliminieren
plötzlich im raum standen unter anderem
hat die deutsche kulturstaatsministerin
monika grütters von kultur barbarei
gesprochen andere sprachen von zensur
oder davon dass eigentlich die rückkehr
der berner hat sie zeit und diese
begriffe von entarteter kunst plötzlich
wieder zurückkehren könnten also
wirklich die allerschwersten geschützt
und das finde ich hoffnungslos
übertrieben das gedicht wird ja nicht
verboten es wird an dieser hauswand
nicht mehr zu lesen sein als
aushängeschild dieser hochschule hat das
nicht also man kann es im internet
nachlesen das haben jetzt auch andere an
ihre hauswände gemalt also man könnte
sagen den studenten die die diesen
protest damals initiiert haben ist hoch
zu danken bei eugen gomringer kannte
vorher so gut wie niemand und plötzlich
sprechen alle von konkreter poesie
also das ist ja ein oft nicht
beabsichtigter effekt all dieser protest
dass man sich plötzlich mit bald mit den
bildern aus der biennale und so weiter
intensiv beschäftigt und trotzdem ist
natürlich das seltsam dass gerade die
studentinnen die da sich so empfindlich
gezeigt haben nicht aussagen könnten
mensch wir tolerieren dass also wird es
uns ist nicht behaglich bei diesem
gedicht wir fühlen uns objektiv ii ziert
also als frauen irgendwie seltsam
betrachtet weil da so ein bewunderer
auftritt der uns nur deshalb als frauen
offensichtlich wertschätzt weil wir
schön sind und nicht weil wir sind viele
sind komisch antiquierte vorstellung
aber sowas wohl damals also das ist ja
immer zu die frage wie gehen wir
eigentlich mit kunstwerken um die nicht
heute entstehen sondern die vielleicht
schon 70 jahre vielleicht schon sieben
und hat jahr aber sind wir werden ja
heute oder vor einigen jahren wurde
dieses gedicht an die fassade gemacht
also der entscheidungsprozess ist ja
jetzt noch mal getroffen worden für
dieses geht ist es interessant für die
wissenschaft ja und es ist erst hat man
gesagt okay eugen gomringer großer
dichter und wir ehren ihn dadurch dass
wir im eines seiner gedichte eben groß
auf unsere fassade mal so war das und
dann gab es die proteste und dann gab es
einen sehr umfangreichen diskursiven
prozess wurde sehr viel gestritten und
debattiert und am ende gab es eine
demokratische entscheidung
man könnte sagen es eine art von
demokratischer ökologismus
da stattgefunden hat wenn man es
überspitzt formuliert das interessante
ist daran und ich glaube da liegt auch
ein bisschen der grund dafür dass es
diese überschießenden reaktionen gab
also kulturbereich und ähnliche sachen
dass die moderne kunst immer auf solche
prozesse eigentlich auswahl also sie
wollte ja nie sakrosankt sein sind
wollte nicht akademisch seien sie wollte
eigentlich immer ein offenes kunstwerk
sein ist ja der begriff von umberto eco
das offene kunstwerk und das heißt dass
sich jeder sein eigenes bild machen soll
das ist eben nicht die kunst gibt
sondern immer die kunst auch von den
betrachtern im prozess des betrachtens
mit entsteht und das partizipation ein
ganz wichtiger anteil dieser
rezeptionsgeschichte ist und viele
museen legen wir größten wert darauf
dass das publikum nicht einfach so als
konsum ist ish an den werken vorbei
schreibt sondern sie sollen eben ihre
eigene meinung bilden und das ist jetzt
klar was haben sie gemacht sie haben
ganz genau das gemacht und etwas anderes
kommt noch hinzu dass wir in der
bildenden kunst immer wieder künstler
erlebt haben
die ihre ängste formuliert haben ihre
traumata zur quelle ihrer kunst gemacht
haben denken sie an joseph beuys oder
marina abramovic und solche leute die
wir nichts ohne ihre erschreckens
erfahrung gewalt erfahrung und wir
erzählen von diesem gewalt erfahrung
zeige deine wunde hat beuys mal eins
seine werke genannt
und man könnte sagen die studenten in
berlin in der diskussion um das gedicht
haben nichts anderes getan als ihre
angst bekundet ihre gefühle in den
mittelpunkt gerückt wir haben gesagt ich
fühle mich nicht wohl mit diesem werk
man könnte sagen sie haben von den
künstlern gelernt offen mit ihren
empfindungen umzugehen was in der kunst
allerdings nicht so vorgesehen war dass
man dann gleich gesagt und deswegen
mussten diese kunstwerke weichen sondern
es war ja immer die vorstellung dass wir
in der reibung das für in der
auseinandersetzung mit einzelnen
kunstwerken mehr über uns selbst lernen
und dass diese reibung deswegen wichtig
und entscheidend ist und es im museum
nicht darum gehen kann
1/11 space zu
errichten und auch das kunstwerk selber
nicht allen in jeder denkbaren hinsicht
gefallen muss und warum wollen wir diese
reibung heute vermeiden
ich glaube wir leben in unruhigen zeiten
wir leben in zeiten in denen die welt in
den augen vieler unübersichtlicher wird
es gibt dieses phänomen der ambiguität
intoleranz heißt das glaube ich ist so
modebegriff also dass menschen ist immer
seltener aushalten dass die dinge so
wahnsinnig komplex geworden sind und in
der kunst sind die dinge nun mal komplex
ist es sogar ihre aufgabe die einfachen
wahrheiten zu hinter spülen oder die
dinge komplizierter zu machen als sie
vielleicht auf den ersten blick scheinen
uns in widersprüche zu verwickeln von
denen wir gar nicht wussten dass sie
gibt und ja auch das schein hafte der
kunst ist glaube ich ganz wichtig dass
wir nie so genau wissen woran sind wir
denn eigentlich was meint er dämpft wohl
dieser zweifel die da überall in der
kunst zum vorschein kommen die machen
vielen menschen zu schaffen und sie
suchen orte an denen es doch noch so
etwas gibt wie gewissheit science
gewissheit vielleicht sogar okay also
dieses unbestimmte dass die kunst immer
ausgezeichnet hat dieses vage
vieldeutige resümierte jetzt zum
verhängnis weil wir es in der welt jeden
tag um unserem herrn und eben die
entgrenzung würde wir vorhin auch schon
sprache der kunst moderne kunst lebt von
entgrenzung es kommen immer neue
materialien neue budgets neue spielarten
der kunst dazu und die überschreitung
das für die genau wissen ist es jetzt
kunst oder es ist nicht kunst also
dieses spiel mit dem leben das hinein
kommt in die kunst das sind ja alles so
von den etwas verunklart wird und diese
entgrenzung ist glaube ich heute
fragwürdiger als sie vormals war was
damit zu tun hat dass unsere
gesellschaften sich liberalisiert haben
also dass wir in gewisser weise alle ein
wenig wie die künstler heute agieren
oder dass dieser traum geben falls ein
künstlerisches leben führen zu können
recht verbreitet ist das haben die
soziologen luc boltanski und la paloma
mit dem neuen geist des kapitalismus
bezeichnet man als grob gesprochen
früher ging es vor allem darum dass
immer diszipliniert sein sollte
ordentlich sein sollte pünktlich sein
sollte gehorsam sein sollte und wie man
sich heute die stellenbeschreibungen
anguckt dann sollen die leute
kreativsein eigensinnig flexibel
wieso hat sich immer wieder neu erfinden
und viele leute wollen das auch
tatsächlich sie finden das großartig
dass sie nicht in der tradition in der
sie aufgewachsen sind gefangen sind dass
sie nicht ihr ganzes leben im selben
beruf tätig sind mit der mit demselben
partner verheiratet sind dass sie ihre
religion frei wählen können das sind ja
alles dinge die uns heute ganz
selbstverständlich vollkommen sie können
überall hinreisen können sich alles in
allen möglichen hinsichten ausprobieren
das ist so vielfältig dass es vielleicht
in der kunst plötzlich darum geht diese
vielfalt auch ein bisschen
zurückzuführen man könnte sagen der
künstler war lange gefragt weil er so
ein protagonist der freiheitlichkeit war
und heute sehen in ihm viele einen
protagonisten möglicherweise auch
wiederum der einhebung oder seien sie
dieser dieser diese vorstellung des
künstlers im fall soll wir an diesem
dritten frage gestellt genau wie an
diesem zuviel der freiheit auch leiden
kommt jetzt sozusagen die gerechtigkeit
er zurück in die kirche und die politik
das waren die spannend in ihrem buch zu
lesen dass wenn man an die biennalen
geht sieht man kunst wird immer mehr
politisch es geht um politische
botschaften es geht um darum dass
minderheiten plötzlich eine stimme
bekommen ja auch in den museen kunst das
ethische wird stärker als das ästhetisch
so könnte man sagen in diesem segment
wir haben es natürlich auch noch mit
einem anderen segment der kunst zu tun
in der es vor allem um geld geht um
repräsentation um status also wenn wir
uns diese superreichen angucken
die nichts dabei finden oder sogar regen
finden plötzlich 10 oder 500 millionen
euro für ein kunstwerk auszugehen
und das ist natürlich etwas was wiederum
auch hinein spielt in dieser
auseinandersetzung in diese kulturkämpfe
die wir erleben also die kunst ist in
allen teil immer stärker zu einem
produkt der reichen geworden und viele
dieser menschen die sehr viel geld
ausgeben eben millionen ausgeben für die
kunst finden auch nichts dabei eben für
dinge geld auszugeben die gar nicht so
besonders toll anzusehen sind wo sich
alle fragen was ist das denn warum gibt
er denn für so ein thema für so einen
schrott derartig viel geld
koalitionsprojekte dann könnte das sogar
für den leonardo so wird sich so fragen
also ein bild das im letzten jahr
versteigert wurde dieser salvator mundi
das christusbild von wem man gar nicht
genau weiß ob es wirklich von leonardo
stammt und es war so stark restauriert
das bild oder ist so stark restauriert
das bild das manche sagen da die
eigentliche künstlerin dieses bildes ist
die restauratoren und dann ist trotzdem
jemand bereit dafür mehr als 400
millionen dollar ausgeben
eigentlich auch selbst haben ja und karl
dieses moment dieses spekulative und
dieses dieses verwundern sie verwundert
das wunderliche daran es jetzt plötzlich
so in den mittelpunkt gerückt und
deswegen gab es in der
auseinandersetzung in new york wir
erinnern uns an das bild von denner
schatz auch den vorwurf nach euch geht
es offensichtlich nur um profit und
vergnügen also dass so viel geld mit der
kunst mit bestimmter kunst verdient wird
macht auch leute sehr hellhörig macht
sich skeptisch und sie haben das gefühl
es geht eigentlich gar nicht mehr um das
eigentliche es geht nicht nur um die
kunst und es geht immer um so neben
absicht investitions gewinne um soziale
dividende und reale behindert
und umso mehr rücken dann wiederum die
ethischen fragen in den mittelpunkt und
man sagt naja also dann müssen wir jetzt
ja wohl offensichtlich mal gegensteuern
und die moral muss ein wichtigerer
faktor werden wie ist um genau dieses
verhältnis zwischen ästhetik und ethik
also gibt es ästhetisch gutekunst mit
einer moralisch schlechten botschaft mit
einer diskriminierenden botschaft zum
beispiel wenn wir uns die historischen
museen angucken dann muss man sagen da
gibt es jede menge fragwürdig motive
also es gibt vergewaltigung sehen es
gibt immer wieder sehen wo menschen
enthauptet werden und man sieht das blut
aus dem körper schießen und man fragt
sich was ist das denn jetzt
also es gibt sehr viel brutalität könnte
man sagen und das sind natürlich bilder
wo man nicht genau weiß was ist jetzt
die botschaft sollen für belehrt werden
wollen uns die bilder zeigen dass für
uns das lieber nicht antun sollten oder
dass wir davon abstand halten sollten
von solchen taten
da ist die botschaft unklar aber die
eigenschaft unklar nehmen wir einen nazi
propaganda für von leni riefenstahl und
der wilde ästhetisch hochwertige macht
ist daran dass ein gutes filmisches
kunstwerk sein
das ist die frage was man dann als gut
bezeichnete und da kann man dann ganz
unterschiedlicher auffassung sein es
gibt leute die sagen mensch die formale
innovation die frage wie werden
bestimmte bilder komponiert ist doch ein
qualitätskriterium
solche bilder gab es vorher nicht oder
solche dramaturgie gab es vorher nicht
oder
die bilder haben eine eigene spannung
die sie herauslösen aus dem
konventionellen insofern muss man sagen
ist eine große künstlerin gewesen weil
sie dinge vollbracht hat die vor ihr
noch niemand so gezeigt hat gleichzeitig
kann man sagen in welchem zusammenhang
waren diese bilder eingebettet und
müssen wir das nicht problematisieren
ist das nicht reine propaganda
also da kann man auch immer
unterscheiden das ist das ist durchaus
möglich formale aspekte und inhaltliche
vielleicht ja also ich meine kunst es
ist nicht immer so einfach es wird
glaube ich umso schwerer je mehr uns die
künstler je näher uns die werke kommen
also bei gegenwartskünstlern denken wir
jetzt an den schauspieler kevin spacey
beispielsweise der als frank underwood
den präsidenten gespielt hatte in dieser
netflix serie house of cards kevin
spacey ist im letzten jahr beschuldigt
worden gleich von mehreren männern vor
allem sich missbräuchlich verhalten zu
haben sie sexuell missbraucht zu haben
möglicherweise sogar und wurde dann aus
der rolle heraus geschrieben und glaube
kevin spacey wird nie wieder nicht den
präsidenten und auch nichts anderes mehr
spielen man wird ihn nie wieder wird nie
wieder mit ihm einen film drehen sie das
und da muss ich sagen es ist schwerer zu
abstrahieren
gerade weil ich weiß nicht ob sich die
serie kevin spacey guckt dann immer so
ein bisschen in die kamera und spricht
zum publikum so als würde er seine rolle
verlassen also spreche jetzt der
wirkliche kevin spacey und nicht frank
underwood und also er spielt mit diesem
diesem wechselspiel von schein und sein
und in dem moment weiß man halt mich
genau ist denn diese figur identisch der
person
und so ist es in vielen werken noch
immer nicht genau weiß also wie viel von
den menschen spielt hinein in das werk
und lässt sich das werk deshalb einfach
mal so abtrennen gibt es da eine harte
grenze zwischen dem werk einerseits und
der person andererseits könnten das
natürlich behaupten das wäre mir sehr
lieb wenn wir könnten ja sagen können
hier ist das werk und da ist die person
und zack gescheitert was bleibt ist aber
dann sind wir schnell an den punkt wo
wir uns fragen warum dann überhaupt noch
zwischen fälschungen beispielsweise in
der kunst zwischen fälschung und echten
werken unterschieden wird wenn es uns
ganz egal ist wann das bild von wem
gemalt worden ist wenn es die biografie
des künstlers nicht mehr interessiert
die entstehungs zusammenhänge
nicht mehr interessieren dann wird
könnten wir uns ja auch die echtheits
frage völlig egal als hein oder
interessant die sind es ist gar nicht
egal sondern wir wollen ja schon
irgendwie wissen wie spiegelt sich die
welt in der kunst und sie spiegelt sich
der künstler in seinen werken der reihe
sondern ich genau und ich meine man hat
diese problematik natürlich in der in
bei vielen künstler in der
kunstgeschichte von picasso bei
caravaggio zum beispiel der verbrechen
begangen haben soll und so weiter und
mörder chaney beispielsweise wenn er so
herrliche bronson hinterlassen hat oder
hans ludwig kirchner von dem manche
sagen er habe mädchen missbraucht und
diese mädchen diesen akt mädchen tauchen
ja auch in manchen seiner werke auf wir
haben hier die kasse und caravaggio
erbracht als beispiele
wir können auch noch einen schritt
weiter gehen und ein bild von adolf
hitler zum beispiel also weil da hat man
sozusagen ein kunstwerk jetzt kann man
sich darüber streitet ob das ein gutes
kunstwerk ist ja oder nicht aber von
einem menschen der böse taten begangen
hat offensichtlich und die frage ist
schon wie färbt jetzt dieses wissen
darum was wäre der künstler ist und was
er getan hat unsere unseren blick auf
das bild und und lässt sich das nach
unvoreingenommen betrachten
und wenn ich sie richtig verstehe sind
sie da so ein bisschen dazwischen sie
sagen wir mal kann nicht genau trennen
zwischen werk und kennst du ich bin ja
von meiner herkunft kunsthistoriker also
ich habe mich immer mit der geschichte
der kunst beschäftigt mit dem
politischen zusammenhängen mit den
sozialen zusammenhang mit dem
biografischen implikationen das hat mich
immer sehr interessiert und trotzdem
gibt es diesen moment ich gehe ins
museum
ich stelle mich vor ein kunstwerk sei es
jetzt ein gemälde oder eine video
installation und schau mal was passiert
und diese offenheit die würde ich auf
jeden fall verteidigen wollen dass man
nicht immer mit vorgefassten meinungen
an ein werk herantritt
also man soll das nicht mehr aussetzen
zumindest also schauen was passiert was
das mit jedenfalls kann ich das für mich
so sagen dass die ästhetische erfahrung
um so intensiver ist je weniger ich
erstmal meine vernunft einschalte also
wenn ich das wissen dass ich habe um
einen künstler immer in den vordergrund
stelle dann sind die bilder auch sehr
schnell abgehakt dann weiß man immer
schon aha das ist ja wohl holzach weiter
also gehen ja auch gerade viele
professionelle kunstkenner mit der kunst
um die schreiten die kunst er ab aber da
haben gibt es verweise die laien einen
vorteil weil sie ein bisschen
unbefangener an die kunstwerke
herantreten können ja man kann auch
sagen die verstehen überhaupt nichts
weil sie einfach die
entstehungsgeschichte nicht kennen sie
wissen nicht was das wovon sich der
kunst abgetrennt sie haben was davor war
was ja nachgaben und so weiter als ich
sagt ja aber sie haben ja ihre
empfindung vermögen und sie haben ihr
ein bildungs vermögen mir vorhin von
geld gesprochen diese art von vermögen
scheint mir viel wichtiger zu sein und
das lässt sich natürlich auch schulen
dieses empfindung vermögen dieses ein
bildungs vermögen das braucht aber so
eine gewisse unvoreingenommenheit dass
man sich den dingen erstmal überlässt
und schaut was kann ich da entdecken was
fällt mir dazu ein womit vergleiche ich
es möglicherweise das heißt nicht dass
die anderen die historischen die
sozialen fragen keine relevanz hätten
überhaupt nicht es gibt an den punkt an
dem ich sage mensch ist ja interessant
dieses werk von rembrandt was hat er
denn sonst noch gemalt wer waren
eigentlich seine auftraggeber wie ist
denn diese komischen wie ist dieses
komische motiv vielleicht zu erklären
woher kommt überhaupt dieses motiv ist
vorgeprägt oder hat er das erfurt all
diese fragen sind total interessant und
trotzdem gibt es dieses moment von reits
und rührung
aber jetzt gibt es ja also neben reiz
und rührung gibt es ja vorwürfe
handfeste der sexuellen belästigung
gegen künstler oder schauspieler wie
kevin spacey in dieser frage wie geht
man damit um
und wird man zum komplizen wenn man
jetzt diese bilder aus hängt oder diesen
dirigenten auch dirigieren manager usw
wie es da ihre haltung es ist ich
wundere mich erstmal darüber was sich
verändert hat
denn wenn ich auf die kunstgeschichte
schaut dann war es ja lange so
das dem künstler dinge gestattet waren
die eigentlich niemandem sonst gestattet
waren
der künstler war so eine ausnahmegestalt
ein genie irgendwie von gott begnadet
und interessanterweise haben schon die
herrscher in der renaissance gesagt wir
erkennen uns im künstler wieder und wir
als herrscher die wir auch das recht
schaffen stehen weil wir ja die schöpfer
des rechts ins nicht unter dem recht
sondern über dem recht und wir kennen im
künstler unseres gleichen 1 1 von uns
und deswegen darf der künstler auch
dinge tun die sie sonst beim land darf
und darf seinem kontrahenten das gesicht
aufschlitzen darf alle möglichen
verbrechen begehen ohne dafür bestraft
zu werden es gibt wirklich also der
kunsthistoriker horst bredekamp hatte
ein sehr interessantes buch darüber
geschrieben kunst und verbrechen wo ganz
deutlich wird der künstler galt als
jemand der außerhalb des rechts stehen
heute ist es zum glück nicht auf zum
glück wenn ja zum glück nicht mehr so
aber möglicherweise begünstigen bestimmt
schaffen strukturen begünstigen
bestimmte rollenklischees immer noch
diese vorstellung dass der künstler
dinge tun darf die sonst niemanden
gestartet sind
ich glaube wir kommen anderen ende
dieser zeit aber die frage ist was damit
einhergeht völlig klar ist der künstler
muss sich vor dem gesetz verantworten
wie jeder andere wollen wir aber dass er
auch dem moralischen standards die wir
heute haben ebenso genügt wie baloise
und da muss ich sagen nein ich möchte
dass die kunst nicht amoralisch ist aber
dass sie ein feld es in dem dinge
erprobt und gedacht werden dürfen
möglicherweise im alltagsleben so keinen
raum haben und das sind eben dinge die
auch über unsere klassischen vorstellung
von anständigkeit hinausgehen oder das
heißt spacey darf sexuelle belästigung
und karriere machen
nein das habe ich nicht gesagt habe ja
ganz klar unterschieden zu sagen der
künstler muss sich an recht und ordnung
halten ja es ist ihm nicht gestattet
andere leute zu knebeln zu einem heute
noch irgendwie auch immer auch nur zu
vergewaltigen
ja aber
innerhalb des werkes beispielsweise wenn
kevin spacey auf der bühne steht dafür
natürlich jemanden umbringen das ist
klar ja na ja das sagen sie so es ist
keineswegs mehr so klar es gab letztes
jahr eine aufführung in berlin ein
theater aufführung wo ein protagonist
das wort [ __ ] verwendete dieser
protagonist sollte ein nazi darstellen
und nazis sagen gelegentlich solche
wörter
da hat dann aber der intendant und wann
gesagt mensch das können wir nicht
machen wirklich weiter sitzen im
publikum leute die sich davon beleidigt
fühlen die sich vielleicht zucker
traumatisiert fühlen deswegen sollte
jetzt der schauspieler dann n beat sagen
hatte dann auch gemacht habe das wort
[ __ ] sollte nicht mehr ausgesprochen
werden es ist heute tatsächlich ja auch
eine beleidigung und ich würde auch
immer sagen auch nicht mal alltags von
einem der alltagswelt sollte es nicht
mehr gesprochen
aber wenn wir sagen auf der bühne dürfen
bestimmte dinge die im realen leben
passieren plötzlich nicht mehr
dargestellt werden weil wir auf der
bühne
sozusagen eine bereinigte wirklichkeit
sehen wollen eine bessere wirklichkeit
sehen wollen dann wird es hochgradig
absurd dann haben wir eigentlich so
verhältnisse wie im sozialismus also der
sozialistische realismus der verlangt er
immer dass die welt auf den kunstwerken
auf den bildern und wie idealer
dargestellt werde als jetzt in der
wirklichkeit dass die arbeit immer ein
sanftes lächeln auf den lippen tragen
wenn sie zur arbeit gehen ja also diese
art von wirklichkeit korrektur auch
nachträglich noch erleben wir dass das
bild titel in denen auch der das wort
[ __ ] vorkommt plötzlich korrigiert
werden beispielsweise in der bremer
kunsthalle nachträglich wird dann die
geschichte in gewisser weise
zurechtgerückt und da muss ich sagen
habe ich wenig verständnis weil die
geschichte ja auch immer eine korrektur
sein kann das für den aha damals war das
server heute ist es anders wir haben uns
irgendwie doch weiter entwickelt also
dieses ergebnis könnte ja auch in der
auseinandersetzung ist haben wir bei den
problemen kommen
wir sind zwei weiße männer und haben
jetzt der stunde lang eine knappe stunde
über sexismus und rassismus in der kurs
und in der gesellschaft diskutiert und
viele würden uns vorwerfen ihr seid die
forschen ja die hier über die so etwas
sagen sie dazu
mich würde interessieren was sie dazu
sagen ich antworte jetzt einfach mal mit
einer gegenfrage ja auch das schöne ist
ich habe mich verändert jedenfalls kann
ich jetzt keine geschlechtsumwandlung
vor dem essen möchte ich jedenfalls
nicht
ich antworte insofern darauf als ich
sage wir versuchen ich versuche
möglichst viele standpunkte möglichst
viele aspekte in meiner argumentation
auch oft zu nehmen und zu hören wer
äußert sich in welche richtung
und vielleicht können wir das nicht
vielleicht können wir bestimmte
standpunkte nicht einigen weil das die
stimmungswerte nein aber das ist ja
gerade die kunst und auch der diskurs
raum der kunst waren ja immer orte
gesellschaftlicher auseinandersetzung
kant hat mal gesagt der sensors kommunen
ist also der gemeinsinn ist etwas was in
der auseinandersetzung über kunstwerke
wachsen kann
ein sinn der sich stärken kann bei wir
gegenseitig versuchen uns dinge
anzusehen also altmodischer begriff aber
dass wir immer wieder versuchen uns
gegenseitig dinge klar zu machen
unterschiede deutlich zu machen
auch möglicherweise unvereinbare dinge
klar werden zu lassen
mehr können wir als menschen glaube ich
nicht tun als den versuch zu wagen uns
gegenseitig immer wieder zu befragen uns
in unseren wahrnehmungen auch zu
korrigieren was mich nur erschreckt bei
diesen diskussionen wie wir sie in den
kultur kämpfe erleben dass es immer
wieder haltungen gibt sie sagen weder
hast du jetzt gar nicht mehr mitzureden
also in der auseinandersetzung über den
schatz da war es dann so dass man sagt
alle die nicht schwarz sind sollten sich
jetzt gar nicht mehr dazu äußern dürfen
und das ist der moment in dem der
diskurs erlischt und in dem dann aber
auch unsere vorstellung von geteilten
werten ist also eigentlich die idee des
universalismus zu einem ende
ja nach unserer sendung kommt zum am
ende hoffen wir dass diese idee des
universalismus dass wir eine eigene
sendung werde aber ich danke ihnen
vielmals für das kommen und für die
herren der stunde
vielen dank ihnen ja nächste woche
blicken wir uns in den sog des bösen wir
zeigen ihnen ein best of der letzten
sternstunde der nacht wo unter anderem
ein mörder zu gast war
und apropos sternstunde danach die
nächste ausgabe zeichnen wir in vier
wochen auf wie immer können sie live mit
dabei sein sichern sie sich jetzt ein
ticket auf unserer webseite und morgen
und am dienstagabend sollten sie
unbedingt das radio einschaltet und
barbara bleisch und ich philosophieren
mit kindern über gerechtigkeit und über
das glück in der sendung zambo jeweils
um 19 uhr auf radio sr f 1 und jetzt
gleich folgt das abstimmungs studio
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]